Robin Williams got rejected twice by the
Harry Potter franchise and nobody could
do anything about it here's why the late
great Robin Williams played many roles
over his illustrious career as he showed
time and time again he was equally at
home with comedy and drama it's no
wonder he was showered with Awards and
nominations for his accomplishments on
both fronts even Landing an Academy
Award for his supporting role in Good
Will Hunting he was often just as
instrumental behind the scenes as he was
in front of the camera in fact he
provided crucial support to Steven
Spielberg when the director was making
Schindler's List with all of that in
mind it's no stretch to say that
Williams was one of Hollywood's biggest
a-listers for much of his career and
made lots of great movies before his
untimely death in 2014. however there's
one very particular Blockbuster
franchise that Rose to prominence in the
early 2000s that even he couldn't manage
to land the role in Chris Columbus
director of 2001's Harry Potter and the
Sorcerer's Stone and 2002's Harry Potter
and the Chamber of Secrets spilled up
see in a new interview with total film
magazine in October 2021 apparently
there was a role Williams wanted to play
in the Harry Potter movies but he
ultimately wasn't able to secure it for
reasons outside of his control who was
this an attainable character it was one
particular werewolf wizard Chris
Columbus explained that Williams
approached him about the role of Remus
Lupine the lycanthrope wizard who is a
staunch Ally of the Potter family
Columbus had no choice to turn him down
saying I had a conversation with Robin
Williams who wanted to play Lupine it
was very difficult for me to say it's
all British there's nothing I can do
that's not possible
the key Harry Potter cast members are
indeed all of British descent so
Williams was tragically unable to land
the role he so wanted to play still
while it would no doubt have been
interesting to see William's take on the
tragic character that is Remus Lupine
the wizard was in good hands all the
same Lupine was portrayed by actor David
thulis of Fargo and Wonder Woman Fame
who did a great job with the intense
role and helped make the character the
fun favorite he is today in addition to
Remus Lupine it turns out Robin Williams
had some measure of interest in playing
a different beloved Harry Potter
character as the first film was getting
off the ground speaking to HuffPost in
2016 Sorcerer's Stone casting director
Janet herschelson shared that he also
wanted to play rubius Hagrid sadly for
Williams much like with Lupine the
British Only Rule also prevented him
from playing the half giant wizard that
the late Robbie Coltrane portrayed so
perfectly throughout the Harry Potter
franchise
Without You Hagrid
well he didn't share his thoughts on
William's hypothetical take on Hagrid
Chris Columbus has expressed his
personal feelings on how he thinks
Williams would have done as Lupine he
told Insider in 2021 Robin would have
been brilliant it would have been a
different interpretation I thought David
thulis was Grace but Robin would have
been brilliant considering William's
impressive acting range and the
commitment he seemed to have for each
and every one of his Parts it stands to
reason Columbus isn't far off here
there's no doubt Robin Williams would
have made a wonderful Wizard but at the
end of the day Robin Williams inclusion
in the Harry Potter Saga never came to
pass the characters were brought to life
by other talented actors and the film
sent on to make serious cash and become
adored the world over meanwhile Williams
continue to Grace our screens with his
own kind of magic wizard or not
foreign